no triple digits in las vegas this
weekend that will change today and as we
go through the week there will be a
warming trend sherry's off today your
most accurate weather now forecast love
this view from our camera on top of the
red rock resort not much movement with
the palm tree had a beautiful full moon
last night this is the pre-dawn's early
light sun doesn't get until after six
officially we're at 76 degrees but
what's happening in your neighborhood
dipping down to the 60s right now for
centennial hills and alliante
downtown and the strip were at 80 an
hour ago so all of that overnight heat
is beginning to rise back up into the
atmosphere of course in the next hour
we'll start to turn things around uh
death valley close to the triple digit
mark take away 20. laughlin you're at 77
elsewhere around nevada and beyond into
the 40s right now in ely we'll show you
the smoke map from the wildfires much
worse over extreme northern and western
nevada cedar city good morning with your
61. so the weather headlines beautiful
day today we'll see some of that smoke
and haze tomorrow and then there's that
warming trend we mentioned for today 102
will put us right at normal current
temperatures low so far this morning air
quality in the moderate category so at 5
00 am most of the smoke over northern
nevada next 24 hours southwest wind will
bring some of that right into our
backyard and then for your family and
friends leftovers from tropical storm
andre are still dumping on the new
england states and may affect
southeastern canada your eight day
forecast we'll do 102 again tomorrow
with that smoke and then start that
warming trend 106 thursday 107 on friday
then cutting back a little bit those
won't be records but they will be war